[Musique]
il s'appelle joseph un bonheur simple et
tranquille dans la silence frémissant
d'un automne en lorraine 1 pas égale une
cigarette une grande patience fait de
l'avis même des choses à brise lentement
au rythme des quatre saisons
voilà une amanite tue mouches white
shabak lé point dessus vous voyez est
pourquoi on l'appelle tue-mouches
postuliez mouche comme des moules
semaine dessus
alors seulement la chair est blanche
tandis que l'autre elle est rose le
rouge comme il appelle ce n'est pas
comestible
s'il n'est pas comestible et ses grandes
passions la celui-ci c'est un set à la
terre comme l'appelle vulgairement
lavasoft alors avec ça ils ramassent
pour faire la pénicilline avec le les
sports qui tombe il faut de la télé se
libérer et c'est pas comestible il n'est
pas comestible
il a aidé geste on ferme en jeu mais
n'est pas fameux il n'est pas bon pas
bon du tout
[Musique]
ça commence à tirer un vrai oui alors
voici la corne d'abondance
elle est connue la trompette de la mort
en trompette de la mort bigard moi ni
trompettes de la mort sacha nu-pieds tlv
voyez vous allez voir très comestible
très comestible
valera sur le livre il est là parce que
vous avez un livre un livre on ne peut
pas se tromper il y a encore du pilot au
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est le
pilot ça ils sont comestibles mais pas
fameuse et voici le club vert jaune
moyen du clavaire ils sont comestibles
journée seulement comestibles c'est très
joli ce que j'allais tandis que l'autre
le rouge le bleu le il ya de plusieurs
sortes de plusieurs couleurs
il vous sous la halle et coliques un bon
voilà maintenant est encore là l'homme
de baisse o les langues deux fois oui
ont suivi ce que ça je vis que oui
saison c'est bon ça oui les soeurs
égorgées dans l'ue un peu de vinaigre
avec de l'eau un peu de persil dedans
après vous les peluches et après vous a
coupé en tranches et vous la faites
cuire comme un bus tec la même chose
bien dites moi si on allait manger tout
ça si on aspire une omelette du naturel
moi c'est ça ça pose à quoi les ariège
déchets ramassés vous remettez tout ça
dans lequel jours et on va faire une
rendu lé attendu sur un bon feu de bois
[Musique]
vous auriez déjà fait le métier là comme
moi je fais d'un bonhomme
vous pourriez plus impatients on a des
joueurs qui veut aller à la pêche
il faut qu'il aille à la pêche qu'il
pleuve qu'il vente qu'il faut faire pour
que le temps ils veulent à la pêche
- c'est le champion qu'il pleuve qu'il
vente qu'il neige pour que l'eau salée
shopping contre le mans
si vous étiez riche qu'est ce que vous
feriez si j'étais riche c'est très riche
varié toujours dans les bois je me bâtir
une belle maison dans le bois guy
boussekey mettant à l'eau pour pêcher et
chasser les envier aux champignons à
nous appelons jamais ouvrir des
champions jamais parce que quand je pars
d'ici
croyez moi je regarde le bois tristement
disant est-ce que je reverrai encore
l'année prochaine
je ne sais pas je deviens vieux mais je
fais ce que je te reverrai encore
l'année prochaine tu me fait gagner ma
vie déjà toi au bois c'est vrai ça
toutes les anecdotes pas que je garde le
bois qui c'est la dernière fois que je
viens
fini ma à l'année prochaine pour le
moment
tous les ans nous étions même l'âge de 5
6 ans de 10 comme ça la même chose je
reviens toujours
j'espère encore une arrivée prochaine et
en coop de deux ans aux côtés de 3,2
kepa
[Musique]